[Music]
in Bella backlash news submitted by
Franklin makini I mean there's a lot of
Franklin's in the nuts by Kitty you
learn how to use the laptop yeah yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
Bella Hadid apologizes for Instagram
post that some said disrespected Arab
country what is it yeah by the way I
just realized this is such a confusing
set up you have never been here with me
all girls cat boom boom ah any what song
was that theme song and I'm here to say
I you know leave it further back yeah
1980
anyway Bella Hadid here so yeah so Bella
Hadid posts a picture of oh by the way
if you didn't know what Bella Hadid
looks like she finds she's so beautiful
Hadid ago on that date is dating the
weekend right she was just feeling much
about her this is breaking was and I
just found out about this on s3 I'm
yesterday not when you see it but like
today in the present yesterday okay
anyway so Bella Hadid right she's on
Instagram stories she's a supermodel
jet-setting
flying all over the world living the
life doing her [ __ ] and she posts this
on our Instagram stories I never won
another one
yeah and it's right is so offensive
about that okay yeah that's what most
people that didn't understand what the
outrage what is that that's her foot she
gets her boot and it she's at an airport
she's just showing she's at an airport
and then it's parked tons of hate like
massive he outraged people started the
hashtag Bella Hadid is racist
I don't know if she's wearing it bloats
it just looks like she's posted a
picture of her shoes like ham I mean I'm
the supermodel and I'm buying if she
races against witches no no she is not
because of her shitty fashion supermodel
yeah so she saw tons of people were
sending like death threats they were
like death yeah it's being death threat
totally just like [ __ ] you Bella Hadid
Oh talk like you racist book your hope
die like that kind of thing oh yeah she
means it's like whoa like dude oh just
posted a picture like calm down yeah so
apparently the sole showing the soul of
your of your shoe towards your someone
that you dislike is like one of the like
flipper name off yeah like it's like one
of the worst insult you could amass call
them and they don't kind of but the
bottom of the shoe is bad yes like
they're like oh thank you yeah come
again come again
exactly you'd be like mmm oh yeah so if
you look in the picture the bottom of
her shoe is mounted at these like arab
arab arab airlines
people were like that is so [ __ ]
racist I can't believe you hate our our
countries our communities but she's of
what is she looks her by the middle east
is actually like now the big shank has
Arab and she's supposed to know better
she should know better her dad her dad
is like his heritage ya know this I
think she she didn't I guess you know
like maybe she's America night yeah it's
a stretch she's very Americanized here
and me is the name kind of and her dad
is like hello yeah yeah and so for a lot
of people in a lot of countries they had
no idea about this they were just like
whoa where is this coming from
and yeah so it turns out like it was
because of that and then she issued an
apology which oh you maybe you can read
this oh she has an apology that she
posted following this hate okay the
whole thing yeah okay I always mean yeah
I'll do it in your best Bella Hadid
voice hi all
I'm posting this to clear up a few
things okay
hi I'm hosting us to clear up a few
things that I have been that have been
weighing on my heart she's really doing
it she began I would never want my posts
or platform to be used or for hate
against anyone especially those of my
own beautiful and powerful heritage I
love and care so much about the Muslim
and Arab side of my family as well as my
brothers and sisters throughout the
world
okay boring yeah not only you do I have
Sudan one point five peace okay Elliot I
have so much respect from the bottom of
my heart I have always tried to stand up
for what I feel is right especially
regarding the great Middle East
I have never will never be one of want
to talk down to those countries only to
spread love and the true beauty of them
the way the way I was taught by my TED
talk and my father to feel as if I have
disappointed you is what hurts me bar
you chemically like I'll sum it up it
had nothing to do with the planes she
didn't even know the planes were there
she wasn't like trying to disrespect
them she's like I'm sorry this wasn't my
intention in sincere apology over the
case yeah and that's basically it it was
a huge misunderstanding
yeah poor girl well can you imagine like
if we saw like some guy from a country
yeah like it's just as an American flag
and he's like this and he's just like oh
this is look at this this is really cool
he's like yeah when you to it but we're
like you're flipping off the American
flag isn't enough movies I don't know
but that's also like maybe in their
culture they're like it's enough movie
starts and enough show so you know what
I mean and like I think the difference
is white people are saying and it's like
you're part of that culture so you
should know and yeah and she was
visiting those countries like you're
there you should know but I mean it's
kind of scary because like if you think
about it she only really put her foot up
you know so for someone like us imagine
if we went would we get the same kind of
backlash yeah I think they they called
her races but you can't be racist
against your own race I mean you can
show patient turn the lights racist up
but still it's like that's dumb okay
yeah maybe wouldn't we we might get like
the corner you don't know yeah like you
it like if you don't know it's actually
pretty good because like if I ever
traveled to those countries now I know
not to do that and yeah and there's like
a lot of things like that like the
putting the chopsticks in your rice to
start anyway or that kind of thing yeah
yeah it's really a key habit yeah cuz
that's like death Oh boodles
but Kingsley taught me that he always
does it and I'm always like feeling
uncomfortable and like stop you taught
me not to do is why are you doing this
like it I'll see if you know and you
still do it that I don't know how to
help you yeah he's like I mean that's it
they just represent oh you'll stab it
yourself hater
I don't know right so he says he doesn't
believe in it but he just wanted to like
share the knowledge it's public it's
public like what is knowledge common
knowledge or no no public actions what's
the word acts have been be saggy decency
I can't think of it no nevermind [ __ ] it
I'll remember it later and then I'll
scream it out I want to know later
Wow your turn to Joe be playing a flute
like oh yes that's wild dude I've never
been to a country and like I've been to
many countries you ever die now this guy
I have okay I'm culture now you ever
been to a country and did something like
like that you didn't know was wrong yeah
I did this thing one time I didn't know
about this so I was dating a Korean guy
he was my boyfriend at the time um I go
and I meet his like I think it was his
uncle or something and I was like oh hi
and I went and I shook his hands but in
Korean culture never supposed to do that
oh you don't touch others yeah you wait
for this suit what you're supposed to do
is you're supposed to bow and if they
extend their hand then at that point
they've they've opened that up for you
to do that but other than that you're
not supposed to do that and I was all
like my American ass like hey I you know
I don't think they know they don't know
that though that Americans shake hands
they do know that but you were over
there
no I was here he didn't get I didn't get
in any sort of trouble or anything but
he was just saying we don't do that so
I'm like oh okay cool now I know I think
it's as simple as like for example for
us Mexicans it's a we kiss on the cheek
right and here in the US it's like hug
and so a lot of times you like or on
shake a lot of times you're like mom you
know what I mean like you don't know
what the [ __ ] to do with someone and
like especially if it's like an older
magazine completely I mean do I shake do
I hug do I kiss like I don't know what
to do you know but I think the reason
why people are giving her so much
backlash here is because you're supposed
to know you're part of that country like
you claim it and you are it is yeah like
if you claim it so hard and when you use
it to monetize and tomorrow and claim
that last name why don't you know like
part of that culture also it was like
the plains we're like in the background
and then
like she caught the Sun on the corner
and then she made her caption all cute
like I think the last thing that she
thought was like I'm healing at the
plains and there wasn't like a person
was standing there and she was like my
foot - you sir yeah it was like she said
yeah yeah you could tell them in an
airport yeah and then imagine like
having to flip someone off like that
where you have to go like who I wish I
could make up my own thing to get
triggered my own things to get triggered
by like oh yeah like friends friends is
a great show um like like if I go to
Japan and they bow at me I bet oh my god
like this is the one that it's like this
that's bad okay so now we're just doing
all this so now in today's culture you
have to do anything in people gonna know
I feel like now in today's culture
something I didn't know is when you do
that okay sign like this like now that's
white power
oh dude because apparently like like the
racist like it's a lot of this [ __ ] is
started by force yeah that's kind of
[ __ ] like they'll start some [ __ ] on
4chan and they'll get mainstream media
to pick it up and and like they pick it
up like it's a real legit I went to a
restaurant like a no it's I do it all
well I mean I used to do it all the time
and I went to her on and like basically
I sat down and like the guy who like
brought me like a chair and I was like
oh thank you and it was like mainly
blacks like guys who worked there it was
a black dude I pulled it up to me I was
like oh thank you and he's like oh and I
was like oh [ __ ] like no like that's not
what I meant
you know I didn't even know that
permeated like the black oh yeah why cuz
if mainstream media picks it up then
everyone thinks oh so real but no but it
is a real thing like a lot of one
exhausting though like immediately
everyone like in the Turks social
Society has to be like oh that's okay
yeah you think now we got to do that I
mean it is it is but I hope we keep this
that means you want to put it in
someone's pie
someone believed I could hear that I had
totally heard that that's like I don't
know if it's a comes up or what it is
but there yeah that this means I put in
someone's butt but you're right about
getting offended and you don't even have
to do anything if you don't do anything
they say you're your to neutral you're
not adding your voice or your platform
to make a difference or whatever yeah
but in Singapore you can't chew gum and
I didn't know that things I didn't you
got but someone warned me like I could
have like I had gum in my purge they
sell it no they don't tell anybody
yeah you're it's like it's outlawed in
the whole country
yeah yeah I know yeah littering if you
litter you can get a thousand dollar
fine and if you don't pay it like right
away like you go to jail well in Japan
when we were in Japan uh they were
saying that we can't walk and eat
because they disrespect you're supposed
to stop and eat where you're standing
but a lot of us were like well we gotta
keep going
they had fines for people or like vines
for smoking in public fines for a lot of
stuff where in Japan like in a certain
town not like in every town cuz but I
just saw this I did see the no smoking
ones and then I did see that don't walk
and eat signs whenever at that one
market and like trying food and a lot of
people were just walking and eating that
we're foreigners but there's signs
everywhere that yeah they're like don't
woman but people still did it well it's
like why is that a rule so we're at
their own cultural reason because they
don't want your like Oh yep someone's
yumm okay I'm not I'm just trying to
understand they're young you said it's
weird
no I did it I said but why yeah go we
won the tape please well it's like why
is that a rule so weird tell us who the
winner is a [ __ ]
thank you I will clean this crowd now so
that was a fun
[Laughter]
[Music]
you
[Music]